ins Community Video mit Daniel brül hat
sich ausgerechnet Steffi von Silbermond
reingeschmuggelt da gibt's nämlich eine
peinliche Situation wieso weshalb warum
jetzt im Community
Video Daniel mich würde es interessieren
ob du bevor du die Rolle in krabbert
gespielt hast das Buch gelesen hast ja
ich habe das das Buch natürlich gelesen
früher war das bei uns
m Pflichtlektüre an der Schule und ich
glaube ich habe damals sogar eine eine
Eins ausnahmsweise mal in dem inem
Aufsatz gehabt als wir das Thema
Krabat behandelt haben also als wir das
Buch gelesen haben das war damals eins
meiner absoluten Lieblingsbücher da war
ich so 12 oder 13 und schon damals fand
ich die Rolle tona ganz ganz cool
insofern war es sehr sehr
lustig wie lange später 15 Jahre später
oder wann das war diese Rolle dann
tatsächlich zu spielen und das Buch war
mir noch total präsent ich habe es dann
noch mal gelesen kurz V vorm Dreh und
hat mir immer noch total gut ge fallen
hey Daniel wir haben jetzt die
Möglichkeit ne da ja dieses tolle Team
gerade dann jetzt auch gleich zu dir
kommt dir eine Frage zu stellen und
eigentlich ist es nur eine Situation die
ich kurz erzählen will ne wir laufen wir
wohnen ja im gleichen Stadtteil Berlins
ja deswegen sehe ich dich ab und zu mal
und ich lauf mit meinen Eltern auf der
Straße lang und tatsächlich hast du vor
einem Restaurant glaube ich mit
mit ein paar Freunden gestanden und wir
laufen an dir vorbei und meine Mutti
dann ganz laut wir waren wir waren noch
gar nicht richtig an dir vorbei meine
Mutti ganz laut das ist doch dieser
Schauspieler und es war mir so
unglaublich peinlich weil du genau in
dem Moment habe ich mich so umgedreht
und du hast genau aufgeguckt und ich
wusste du weißt bestimmt auch gar nicht
wer ich bin aber du hast es gehört was
meine Mutti gesagt hat ja und da habe
ich gesagt meine Mutti soll es nie
wieder machen D wenn sie jemand bekannt
sieht das so laut auf der
Straße zu sagen das ist eigentlich das
einzige da war jetzt gar keine Frage
dabei ne aber aber eine eigentliche
Frage dein Lieblingsplatz in Berlin wenn
man schon mal dabei ist würde mich mal
interessieren ich glaub ich kenne sie
natürlich und ich
die das stimmt auch dass wir uns schon
mal begegnet sind ich weiß nicht ob in
irgendeinem
Supermarkt gehst du auch bei
kaiserseinkaufen irgendwie also
wahrscheinlich meinst du da so winstraße
winskies da habe ich mal lange gewohnt
ich wohne jetzt nicht weit jetzt erkläre
ich wo ich wohne Hausnummer
Etage auf jeden
Fall ich ja wir sind uns schon paar Mal
begegnet ich liebe peinliche Situation
deine Mutter ist jetzt schon sympathisch
hätte meine sein können
also lieben Gruß an die an die Mutter
und Lieblingsort in
Berlin neben dieser Bar natürlich und
ich hoffe du kommst auch mal vorbei und
und und dann lade ich Dich ein auf
ein nicht nur auf ein Getränk sondern
auch auf mehrere es gibt dannusagen wie
trebtor Park finde ich total
super da bin ich da bin ich sehr gerne
bei diesem Soldaten man mal da von den
von den Russen das ganz ganz irren Ort
SAS kannst dann auch nur in Berlin geben
ich bin immer öfter sehr gerne in
Kreuzberg muss ich sagen nicht nur wegen
der Bar sondern auch weil ich im Moment
finde dass die die die die die schönsten
Clubs und Restaurants und
wars hier sind und ich bin ja ein
totaler prenzlauberg und Mitte Fan aber
es hat sich so ein bisschen für mich
jetzt verlagert weil ich das Viertel
Kreuzberg eigentlich gar nicht so
richtig gut kannte und jetzt immer
besser kennenlerne und dem triptor Park
tatsächlich finde ich ein super ein ein
super Ort hi dan mein Name ist Jeanette
und meine Frage an dich ist an welchem
Set hat dir besonders viel Spaß gemacht
zu drehen und
warum liebe
Jeanette Frage die ich schwer
beantworten kann weil es gab so einige
Sets die ich sehr genossen habe es gab
für mich so verschiedene Highlights das
also als ich angefangen habe war das
weiße Rauschen ein ganz ganz wichtiger
Film für mich und das waren sehr
experimenteller Film das war so kein
kein
normaler kein normaler Dreh sondern sehr
anarchistisch sehr sehr sehr sehr wild
und manchmal vermisse ich das wieder so
zu drehen ne also viel zu improvisieren
und
und spontan einfach auf neue Impulse
einzugehen und so weiter und so fort und
das Drehbuch auch stark zu verändern und
so also das das war ganz toll dann ist g
by Lenin mir immer noch ein ganz ganz
wichtiger Film
weil da habe ich einfach tolle neue
Kollegen kennengelernt fast alle Waren
aus dem Osten also da habe ich auch
Berlin überhaupt erst kennengelernt als
Stadt so richtig und darauf hin mich so
dann in die Stadt verliebt dass ich dann
auch hier hinziehen
wollte in glorious bards war eine tolle
Erfahrung weil wir in im alhwiigen
Babelsberg den Film gedreht haben ist ja
jetzt irgendwie 100 Jahre alt
geworden vor kurzem und das ist
natürlich in so einem tollen Studio wo
schon so irre Filme gedreht wurden und
Filmgeschichte gemacht wurde auch mal
stehen zu dürfen und zu arbeiten war
ganz besonders toll und natürlich noch
toller mit so einem verrückten wie wie
Tarantino und mehr Community Videos gibt
es natürlich bei KCK und z.B das mit
Apple war pictures die über ihr nicht
ganz einfaches Verhältnis zu ihrem
Vermieter berichten oder das mit Hans
saarpai der darüber siniert was er
machen würde wenn er in der Zeit
zurückreisen könnte jo also eins von
beiden ist sicher nicht ganz
uninteressant auf jeden Fall sehr lustig
und ansonsten bis dann bleib
dran